how's it going my name is pea Welcome To
The Moon gorgeous look at this we don't
have a lot of time left to waste John is
about to die and we need to find out
what's going on there's obviously
something in by the river I don't know I
feel like they're kind of prolonging the
story
[Music]
for I don't know it's funny but like
just tell us what's going on already ah
you can smell that squirrel and need to
run over all the way from here now
that's
disgusting okay let's go up and talk to
Dr
Watts if he's even
there no he's not
here how is John doing barely hanging on
what are you two doing we just we just
couldn't make any progress you better be
soon we don't have long if you're
looking for your colleague I think he's
in the
kitchen God damn hang in there John
solve this it'll make you die
Happy Kitchen where is the kitchen maybe
over here I didn't check out the other
rooms so I don't really know oh no I
understand that part but oh he's calling
like in the last episode he said did you
confirm in his records and why again was
since information not aable to us or the
medical doctor for that
matter where did you get that
coffee are you speaking with headquarter
yes I'll F in later but now
sh okay wait isn't this where did you
find it in the lighthouse before we
started now for the last time
sh the last paper rabbit River again
game to down
a that's
soide I'm not sure I have to check on
that okay we need coffee I guess I don't
know what I'm going to
do right that part we can
do H I see I see but what if okay I
suppose
so what what am I doing
here he waiting for him to but what if
okay that's
okay I I thought
I'm I'm not sure we where's the
C okay I
guess what are we supposed to do oh oh
oh oh Light House Lighthouse we're going
to the lighthouse I'm stupid
sorry
I can't think of anywhere else to go at
least cuz we went alone with Dr wats and
maybe he missed something that she she
uh she
didn't better go see if Neil has any
idea okay [__] that was not
it but he's on the phone what am I
supposed to
do don't be on the phone
Neil
[Music]
but what come
on well I guess we can go upstairs
again
[Music]
uh what what am I missing
here
I'm missing
something I can see the time why can't I
see the time all of the
sudden okay we never went here
[Music]
so oh but Mom I don't want to go to
school it's Sunday
dear shh let them
[Music]
sleep okay
maybe I will maybe I won't you
know T it off you giant doofus yeah you
owe me a peach ball uh
what but it was the beastly as Peach
ball oh man that part oh a I almost
stepped on
paint I guess we're just looking for
Clues right
[Music]
now uh a Pilgrim's guide to arm Rami the
key of of
avoiding
for I don't really feel like reading
this right
[Music]
now
okay those two shouldn't have stayed up
Lade but I should have watched them well
it's not an everyday circum I know but
I'm just so exhausted I'm sure you're
even more so I really need to take a
seed if there's anything you wanted to
ask let me sit down
[Music]
first well I don't
know oh was there something you wanted
to ask you know it's pretty unusual for
someone like you to work here with two
children all I mean it's not that bad
really there's a schull bus that passes
through here but how did you even end up
here well a few years ago my husband
passed away what happened he was in the
Army there were were the last batch to
be deployed overseas sorry to hear I
panicked our savings were low and the
job market was G oh sorry this place was
peaceful too it helped me with my
grieving doesn't the gination grants to
war widows yeah don't they they do and
eventually I received aid but by then
Johnny was starting to have trouble on
his own and he needed my help Tommy and
Sarah like this place too and we
stayed as for Johnny he was glad as
well we're going to miss him and I think
deep down here really wanted a family a
that's so
[Music]
sad what about the future this is your
full-time job what will you do when this
is over what else is there to do find a
job in a city and live I suppose it's a
shame though I'm going to miss Johnny in
this place maybe I'll come back to visit
every once in a while
[Music]
I guess that's it for now oh no I said
no more questions oh
hey before Johnny fell unconscious he
told me that you two would probably be
coming soon he said that he probably
wouldn't get the chance himself but he
wanted me to tell you thanks for
him so thank
[Music]
you
okay we never went over here so let's
check out over
here that's the
bathroom
yes why can I do
that ah butet wait wait let's check if
Neil is not busy anymore this is getting
a little
Annoying
Neil girl yes finally hm what is
it it seemed like our Little Johnny here
has some hidden records from the old
days I knew it tell us hidden records
hidden medical records to be
[Music]
EXA apparently during his use he would
admitted a large dose of enhanced Bea
blocker ah what luck they tend to have
this little side effect on a curious
thing called
Memories beta
blockers John didn't have a heart
condition did he apparently not which
leads one to wonder if the side effects
were intended to merely just that to do
that to begin
oh in such a large amount what happened
there's something missing oh my God it's
impact on his memories it's time in have
been
significant if you you think that's what
kept us from his earliest memories well
it's not the machine I tell you that the
maintenance department yell at me for
scolding them
so what now I just give the recogn rec
reconfiguration frequency that could
should get us back as blockers and once
we're in this childhood it might finally
be early enough to transfer his deire
for it to work then what are we waiting
for but just one thing of course there's
always that one thing in order to
activate the new frequencies we'll need
a trigger a trigger something that exist
strongly in the bridging inacessible
memory and we'll need to give it to John
for him to simulate his home inter what
do we need know that I've only gotten
glimpse of his childhood memories and
even if we find a childhood photo or
something John's
unconscious yeah back to square
one this is difficult think pills you
know this job hasn't been such a pain in
the arts for me since Norah Kid last
year
likewise this is killing me I'm going
out to get some fresh air come on dude
let's just solve it we can do
it he's going to take the coffee I
forgot my yeah I knew
it he was pretty quick on that beta
blocker there's something there's always
something oh that was qu
it the dead Squirrel quit barging in and
out doors the rad K Eva it smells I know
it's your fault from running over it
what's going on the children are still
sleeping wait a
minute that last memory the one where we
stuck
a it was the same smell what are you two
talking about the old factory replicate
are directly linked to brain's limbic
system Lily they're going to use the
smell to sink it don't you see what this
means don't you see what this means um
what it means that that smell is
arguably the most effective sense for
memory recall we can use it as the
stimulant to bridge his memories and the
best part even though John is still in C
he's
still I I think I'm missing some vital
contextual info on this whole thing all
right this is good this is awesome no
you just go and fetch that piece of road
kill yes I'll just what why should I
fetch it you're the one who ran over it
exactly I already done my part well well
said man oh you miserable
bastard um if it helps
I yeah that's right you go get it I have
a pair of gloves you can
borrow they aren't really dis disposable
gloves but that'll probably change after
this good point so I'm wearing the
gloves now is that it I really have to
go and do
this are you
serious all right fine I got blue gloves
B I got blue gloves I got blue gloves
and you like it girl you like it I got
blue gloves and you like it girl you
like it you like it girl you like it
tell me how much you like it uh-uh I got
blue gloves and you like it you like it
uhuh you like it you like it what what
are you doing ah D
it yeah like the last time I got blue
balls I mean glue gloves in you glue
what okay let's just get the road kill
and get this over with I don't see why
we have to do this this this just gross
in my
opinion where are you going
girl got it this kind of things this job
gets me
into it's not safe to just bring in a
piece of GM infected roadkill like this
there's a vault containing in the car i'
at least make it a door controllable
it's good
point again I don't really see why I
have to do this in the
game but hey it's not my
game what's going
on whoa where are you
going
I I got to go take a leak okay I don't
think that's it no I
don't what a mess the crash shook
everything
up let's
see what what is she doing ah there it
is valve
container now to get some of that dirty
road kill okay I get it because now he
will catch up with us that's why they
made us do that
ah and we got the road kill actually
it's still there oh she only took the
smell really okay can you I guess you
can do
that I wouldn't I wouldn't risk it I
would probably take it in the container
this is my my opinion I'm picking up
dead squirrs but you know
what that's a nice beach ball right
there that's the ah there there he is oh
hey did you get the road kill it's ready
great go get it set up I'll be right
back what is he going to do where are
you
going I I got to got to go feed my dig
girl pet
what yeah do that I've been filling
retra anyway hurry and go get things up
I'll be there in no time what are you we
got some one dying back
there that's I don't think that's what
he's going to do it what the potato is
he up
to I have no time to check him out
now just give him the memory girl just
do it just do it everything will be fine
everything will be
Splendid everything will be oop superer
D
super so when we get to to that exact
point I'll send you the signal when I do
I want you to release the valve for
about 3 seconds
certainly about time you showed up have
you made sure the germs are seal up
fully sealed in filter not like it
mattered to a dead
man you should know that Johnny's
condition is
deteriation fast we don't have a lot of
time this might be our last chance you
two what have you doing there good luck
luck luck is the last thing we
need
okay you know what
BR next episode we continue in act
three like andv if you enjoyed subcribe
to and I'll see you in next
episode there we go
this is not creepy I have a gun
[__] dangerous D oh nailed
it what the [__] on the mock was
that don't don't don't do
it I don't even know what's going
on